Modules in Unreal represent a single, linkable library of functionality.
And there's a number of reasons why we might want to break our game up into modules straight out of the gate.
Whether we want very granular control of what gets deployed with particular targets,
or we've got a game of significant size that really crumbles under the link times,
or maybe we just want to break our game up into reusable pieces. Modules are the way to go.
Simply put, an Unreal game is a single EXE built from module libraries,
the most important of which being the primary gameplay module.
This module acts as the entry point for the EXE, and for the most part it is considered the glue for the rest of the game.
Modules are free to link to other modules depending on what functionality they want.
For editor targets, each module will produce a DLLEach,
which is stored in the project binaries folder of your working directory.
In a shipping target, we produce a single, monolithic executable.
As a quick example of how we might find a game structured when using the module approach,
let's consider spinning up a new project and let's call it FPSGame.
We'd find that Unreal will create a primary gameplay module for us, the FPSGame.dll,
and we've now got our entry point.
Now let's start adding features. Let's say we want guns and grenades.
Well, grenades and guns both kind of rely on the concept of projectiles,
so let's make a new module called projectiles that contains an abstracted framework,
and have both of these modules depend on it.
As with everything in programming, these dependencies can be cyclical,
so we should be cautious when we make these connections.
It's a good rule of thumb to have nothing rely on the primary gameplay module if possible.
Having it act as the glue helps reduce headaches down the line.
So how do we actually create a new module?
A module must at least contain the following, and don't worry, we will expand on each shortly.
It requires a working directory, and this is typically located in the source runtime folder.
Within the project folder structure, a module must be defined within a single folder in alongside your source.
So as an example to go with the image above,
we'd create a new test module folder within the source runtime directory.
We will also require a build.cs file, and this file is necessary to the genetic makeup of the module,
but don't worry, we will cover this in more detail soon.
In our example, we'd create a test module.build.cs file within the working directory that we just spoke about.
And lastly we need a module source file.
This source file defines the module class which inherits from the iModule interface and invokes the implement module macro.
The implement module macro is what signals to the Unreal build tool that there's a new DLL that needs to be generated.
A module is primarily defined by its build.cs file.
It's here that we outline what this module depends on and how this module interacts when it itself is depended upon,
and there are two very important string arrays that need populating in this file.
Firstly, we've got the public dependency module names,
and this is a list of what modules this module openly relies on.
In our example from earlier, if guns.dll publicly relied on projectiles.dll,
any import of guns, say we add gun.h to a file in my FPS game,
the linker would also prompt us to import projectiles as well.
Ideally we keep the public dependencies to an absolute minimum.
We want modules to be self-contained pieces of functionality that could theoretically be cut and pasted into a new project with minimal fuss.
Next we've got the private dependency module names,
and these are the modules that this module relies on but internally.
So in our example from earlier again, if guns relied on projectiles but entirely in private or non-API headers,
we can add a private dependency and not force any importing modules to also import projectiles.
But how do we build modules?
Simply adding the code within the module directory is not enough to get the compiler to pick it up and actually compile it.
In order to achieve this, we either need to do one of the following.
Firstly, we can have the primary gameplay module depend on it,
and this can either be as a public or as a private dependency.
Going back to our example with the FPS game, which was the primary gameplay module,
we did not depend on projectiles directly, but we did depend on guns.
These modules are now chained together in a sense and will all get roped into the compile.
If the module doesn't appear anywhere in that chain, it will not get detected by the compiler.
Alternatively, we can add the module to a target.cs file.
And this isn't the typical way of adding a module to the project,
but it is massively powerful if you desire a per-target compilation control.
For example, if you're building a server target, we can add the module to the mygameserver.target.cs file,
which will build it for this target and emit it from the clients.
Similarly, we can add a UI module to the mygameclient target,
and this will emit it from the server targets, which makes sense as a server,
doesn't really have any need for any UI functionality.
This last point is important when considering functionality such as cheats.
If we build a cheat module and emit it from our server and client targets,
then the players can't cheat if the code isn't there to begin with.
We also have the added bonus of stripping out any automation test modules that you may have added
during the development of your project.
Lastly, we also need to add the new module to the list of modules that is held within the UProject file.
This unique file can be opened as a JSON,
and within this file we can add our new module and define two key pieces of data about it,
that being the loading phase and the type of module that we have.
We'll cover what each of these mean in the next slide,
before circling back to the UProject file directly.
Modules themselves can be defined with a load phase and a type,
giving us a massive scope to define how and when a module is allowed to initialise.
Typically they'll fall into one of three categories,
although a great degree of nuance is possible.
You can take a look at the e-host type in the engine for a full list.
Definitions for both e-host type and e-load phase
can be found in the module descriptor.h file.
The first example of a module type would be the editor type,
meaning it only loads when the editor itself is starting up.
Following that we've got the runtime type,
which means it loads on all targets apart from programs.
From there we have developer tool,
which means it's initialised when compiling for targets with the
BBuildDeveloperTools set to true.
This is very useful for defining modules specifically to hold any automated testing
or any tools that benefit in-house development.
And from there we've got server only and client only types,
and these get spanned up exactly where you'd think.
They get spanned up on dedicated servers and non-dedicated servers, respectively.
Load phases are defined alongside the module type to define when a module spins up.
For instance, editor modules tend to get spanned up during the post engine init phase,
whereas actual gameplay modules tend to get spanned up during the default phase,
although the actual loading phase for each module varies depending on the actual use case.
You can see the e-loading phase enum for a full list.
We can see here inside the project file, which was opened just as a JSON file,
we're free to add a number of new modules to the module array,
and it's here that we define the phase and type of the module.
Modules are actually initialised and can quite easily be used as singletons,
with a varying use right across the code base already.
There's nothing stopping us from grabbing a reference to that instantiated module class.
A great example of using modules not just as compartmentalised pieces of functionality within the project,
but as tools in their own right, is when we extend the editor.
Let's consider the following line of code.
The module manager lets us statically grab a reference to the module with the name that we provide.
This name correlates to the name we passed into the implement module macro outlined earlier.
There's nothing stopping us from adding extra functionality to that single mymodule.cpp file,
and using it as a tool or a helper class.
Plugins are a collection of modules broken out into a standalone block of functionality
that can be turned on or off on a per project basis,
allowing for seamless integration with other projects.
Plugins can be developed to do anything that you would otherwise do directly in the project,
say extending the editor, adding a gameplay system or holding in-house tools.
They also reflect the U project's ability to mix and match different module types depending on your use case.
Let's say we want to add a new asset type to our project.
We can create a plugin that consists of a gameplay module and an editor module.
Our gameplay module would hold the new class definitions,
with the editor module handling the creation of that new asset type in the content browser,
adding new context menu support,
and invoking any custom editors that we may or may not have wanted to develop alongside our new asset.
We can see what plugins we currently have installed by opening the plugins menu in the editor,
and we can see that the engine comes with a whole suite of plugins already installed,
covering a massive array of use cases.
We can turn off the ones that we don't want, and turn on the ones that we do. It's pretty simple.
It's here that we can invoke the new plugin wizard,
generating the boilerplate for us so we can start fleshing out our own plugin.
The anatomy of a plugin is staggeringly close to that of the U project itself.
While our U project has got all of its code in a source folder,
all of our plugins are stored alongside that source folder.
Inside our plugins folder, we can see any plugins that we've currently got installed on a project level.
In this case, it's our new plugin, My Plugin.
Within My Plugin, we can see how the plugin itself has got the same architecture as the project.
That being a source, intermediate, content, and config folder,
but with a U plugin file instead of a U project file.
The U plugin file, otherwise known as a plugin descriptor,
acts identically to the U project file.
We can open it up as a JSON and add any modules that the plugin relies on,
just like we would with the U project file.
However, we also see that we have a resources folder.
This folder contains any iconography that we may want to appear in the editor.
By default, it contains the default icon that will appear in the plugins menu,
as pictured on the previous slide.
Plugins can also be packaged, allowing for easy project-to-project integration.
If you're authoring a system that isn't specifically tied to your project,
consider making it a plugin instead.